Oh glob I least antonov the war on
terror is nothing new it's been waged
for years for decades but so far without
success for terror attacks in Brussels
this week are testament to that it's for
war not being waged effectively enough
it's even at the Betty bar you know
Chumley probably gym with standard
central the war on terror will be the
main topic at the International Security
Conference due to be held in moscow at
the end of april the problem is that
some countries are playing games with
the terrorists they think it's possible
to create islands that are free of
terrorism at the UN General Assembly our
president extended his hand and said we
have to stick together if we do we can
come together like a fist it's the only
way that we can fight terrorism Oh buddy
BS terrorism with some ocean dub it's a
haro charlottesville Tata let's go look
at how to like a fist that's a very
illustrative analogy but what part
exactly can rush a play in the war on
terror with a buddy of you well but
immutable I'll give you two examples
first let's look at the Middle East we
have managed to stop the spread of
terror in Syria it would have been even
better to combat it spread through the
whole of the Middle East luckily believe
in your West Oh secondly there's
Afghanistan's done see the words they
were the terrorists there are seriously
endangering security I'm equated suck at
that and we're doing everything to
ensure that this for want of a better
word Phil sure was does not spread to
Russia and the country's friendly to us
elsewhere nah restaurant reduces dinner
that's why we're supplying the armies of
Tajikistan and Kyrgyzstan with modern
weapons were from a co tajikistan here
Jeezy so very minimal we're doing
everything to make their militaries more
effective yo stop opposite voy a tu n'as
boys possibly city for alexia this idgit
recipes at the border between Tajikistan
and Afghanistan is a border that is
hardly patrolled in 2005 where she
withdrew its troops from the frontier
are you planning to return
Anastasia viraemia a career as a dash at
the present time we haven't received any
such requests from our friends in
Tajikistan so far they have only
requested military assistance for their
Armed Forces and weapons for their army
and that's exactly what we are providing
what unlike she'll serve a minimum
righto Shane IAM stole my yellow yes
Russia has a military base in Tajikistan
were some nine thousand soldiers are
stationed the swisha have any plans to
expand it I see we just need you into
college stuff the number of Russian
troops stationed in this space
corresponds to the tasks and challenges
facing Tajikistan and Russia in the
region louisa wave is apostasy
tajikistan I you receive cafe Yahtzee
Tom I Union toast I see Usher places
great importance on military cooperation
with tajikistan who else are you working
with at the pear orchard nothing we're
working first and foremost with our
allies that includes the members of the
collective security treaty organization
and the members of the Commonwealth of
Independent States what hasn't worked as
our cooperation with the countries of
Western Europe astronomy is happening
why not well no problem the main problem
standing in the way of cooperation with
the nations of Western Europe is a lack
of trust in my diplomatic career I've
negotiated and worked with Western
European countries and with the United
States for more than 30 years yeah she's
think i should show during that time I
often had the feeling that I was only
useful to them when I shared their
opinions yes Lee like equator pretty
glorious as soon as I voiced my own
opinion and said that I saw things
differently to them I was immediately
seen as being conservative and
undemocratic diploma tell a tactile a
Buddhist wish I have to offer here we're
watching it and I see what the spreading
of scare stories has to stop stories are
being spread that Russia will send its
tanks into the Baltic States into Sophia
or into Budapest no one intends to do
that there are no such plans
nothing here yet darling Russia does not
want war the very idea of it is
ridiculous smoosh nor a tourist or I see
it's a guy rides away when can we stay
to such stories exist is it fair of a
resurgent Russia or is it may be because
wish I cannot be trusted these days got
it and get nothing it is good give it a
PCM castle destin but i wouldn't paint
all European countries with the same
brush in the Baltic States screaming the
Russians are coming Run For Your Lives
while you still can is a very old trick
it works and has proved very effective
in securing more military spending from
the government and also gaining the
financial support of Western European
countries such as Germany France Italy
and Spain like akaka français de la
espana to what it is like a party those
countries are more pragmatic in their
thinking because they understand that
it's impossible to solve the security
issues affecting Europe with a Middle
East and Asia without Russia's hell is
the surest yusuke figure at sea and put
my stance enough thank you very much for
speaking to us diminish interview